(applaudissements)
- Le coup de départ n'a pas s ss
sont déjà en piste.
- Demain, c'est le jour J.
- Dans un rassemblement
à Louiseville, enffffffffffffffe
Anglade, a dévoilé l'identité
de son président de campagne,
l'ex-ministre des Finances
Carlos LDOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
cheffe, Parti libéral du Québec
- Carlos est la personne tout
indiquée pour être président
Alors, le président de campagne?
- Elle compte sur lui
pour combattre l'inflation.
Il le fera des lignes de côté
porter candidat cette fois-ci.
CARLOS LEITAO, président de de
campagne, Parti libéral du Qc
- Surtout maintenant,
d'une campagne électorale, là,
je me dis : ohoyoy! Ça me manque
un peu. Mais je vais être très
actif pendant la campagne.
c'est que les gens sont
vraime i insatisfaits de
la gestion du gouvernement
par rapport au coût de la vie.l.
- À Montréal, où il se présentes
s'est plutôt dit préoccupé,
lui, par l'avenir du français a.
PAUL ST-PIERRE-PLAMONDON,
chef, Parti québécois
- Je veux pas que Montréal
devienne un Baltimorquququququqe
ce qu'elle est, c'est-à-dire
une ville francophone
et une ville sécuritaire.
- Mais tou
de la Coalition avenir Québec
s'entendent pour dire
que rien n'est joué.
- Moi, je pense qu'on va
Les candidats et les candidates
de la CAQ se sont fait promettre
une limousine et ils sont en
train de magasiner le siège
là. Ici, vous avez que
des gens de conviction
(applaudissements)
- Allô, la Beauce!
- D'ailleurs, le chef
du Parti conserveueur
a poursuivi sa route en Beauce.
Il a lancé sa campagne
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
Parti nsnservateur du Québec
- Pendant ce temps-là,
nos adversaires, ils attendentg.
Bien, nous autres, on n'attendp!
- Là encore, le message
est clair : tout peut arritrtrtr
au jour 1, on veut être premier
au dernier jour de la campagne
électorale, le 3 octobre.
(applaudissement